hello everyone and welcome to day two of
the magnus carlsen invitational
tournament it's an issue versus Maxine
Varsha holograph yesterday we've had
four different players and now we have
another another four players and it's I
think it's the better choice for four
for the audience for example it's better
than if all the players play for example
today and the day after tomorrow and
then everyone gets a rest day but this
way you get four players today four
players tomorrow and then they just
switch in the audience the audience gets
no rest whereas the players are pretty
much always arrested so it is an
interesting concept I don't know if it's
been tried before but we'll see how it
goes so this is actually Game two of
their match I decided not show Game one
even though it was decisive maxime was
able to win that game but it was some
really long theoretical line which was a
complete draw and then Maxime was was
able to win that but I don't know I did
I didn't I didn't think you guys would
enjoy that one I might change my mind
and show it but for now I decided not to
him so this is Game two
now a much more exciting game and now
it's Geary with the white pieces who
should definitely win a game to get back
into the match so without further ado
the Giri goes for d4 sorry about that
and Maxime replies with a d5 and again
this probably came as a surprise to
Geary as if you play d4 of course you
expect Maxime to go for the groom full
defense but here he decided that to go
for something else c4 we have c6 the
Slav defense Knight f3 Knight to f6
Knight to c3 and east six he goes for
that for the semi Slav set up Bishop to
g5 by giri and now h6 a giri trades
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
just III putting his pawns on dark
squares and he's ready to develop his
light square Bishop probably via Bishop
to d3 so g6 by Maxine most common is
Knight nice to d7 but Maxime prepared g6
and it could be that Giri is that Maxime
is actually playing a line that gives
himself
head over the board in the 2019
Sinquefield cup but we're gonna get back
to that so here at night's the e5 by
gearing and Bishop to g7 just continuing
development preparing the castle f4 and
here we have just castles it and now the
game I mentioned in my media reverses
gira from the 2019 a single cup
continued wooden night the b7 Giri went
for this idea and that game ended in a
draw but here Maxine prepared castles
for Giri and here we have Queen to c2
now in that game that we mentioned well
in some other games that reach this
position there were some other moves
played here but Queen the c2 is a new
move by Eyrie so already as we move ten
we have a completely new game and here
Maxine immediately strikes in the center
with c5 freeing up the c6 square for for
his night and the gierek captures it
which is very very unusual as you very
rarely want well get rid of the
attention in the center if you're not
gaining anything but he plays D captures
on c5 and okay Knight to c6 by Maxine
Geary trades
Knight characters B captures and now
Bishop to d3 and Geary now is ready to
castle but Maxime says okay I'm just
gonna go Queen to e7 and you have
doubled pawns here I'm just gonna
capture ton c5 and you will be left with
this well weak c4 pawn so give Reed
offense that even though you could
decide maybe to castle and and give it
up but it is a kind of an important
point so nice the a for defending but
now II five by Maxine and here again if
you if you castle you could they decide
to get your king to say T safety efore
looks really unpleasant you have to go
better back to e 2 and then ideas like
d4 come to mind threatening this if you
capture the in Bishop characters with
the check so black is definitely getting
a passport however you put it so instead
after E 5 we have F capture Sonny 5 by
Gary we have Queen captures on e5 now
threatening to capture on e3 with check
and now it's a question do you defend it
or do you finally say it's it's time to
give up the pawn and castle
so Gary decides that he
not going to defendant he just castles
here at least he has the nice semi-open
F file for his rook Queen captures on
III by maksim King each one and now just
Bishop to e6 continuing development
Geary captures on d5 we a gets rid of
his double bond we have seek after sandy
five and now Bishop captures on d5 Nazi
captors to give white the task C pawn so
Bishop captures and now Bishop to c4
again are hoping to trade here and get a
nice fast pawn here but rook a to d8 now
if captures the rook will be will be the
one to recapture on d5 rook 81 attacking
the Queen and now Queen back to g5 so
here there's a lot of pressure going on
here on the G to square if the Queen
ever moves
so here giri adds another defender to d2
the g2 square and now Maxime finally
trades on C for Bishop characters and C
for Queen captures and the now comes
Luke to d4 which is a bit problematic as
Erie needs to keep an eye on that night
on a4 probably with Queen to b3 but
decides to go for Quinta a6 instead
which also produces some targets here
but that's not where the action actually
is so here Maxime goes for Bishop to e5
he just adds one more attacker to the
game even though rook to h4 is also a
possibility with ideas of maybe bringing
the rook over here you could maybe
sacrifice your own age - and deliver
mate on h5 or h4 but this is also very
nice Bishop to e5 and now g3 you of
course I don't want to allow black any
ideas so Queen to h5 now and now there's
a there's pressure on the rook here if
the Queen ever moves but the real threat
is now Bishop captures and g3 as you
will not be able to recapture so rook
the g2 adding a defender to the g3 point
but now rook the d1 by Maxine and here
white is under a lot of pressure
probably not probably but the the best
way to continue is g4 and other than
that there there are no good moves for
black however for white however giri
decided to play Queen to c4 he decided
that the
Queen has no place on a success all the
action is happening on the King said he
played Queen to c4 but this just loses
terribly to to a certain move and feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this move and a win for Maxine while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the the
double attack and for those who just
want to enjoy the show its Queen to f3
now there's a double attack on the rook
and there's not much I can do
you cannot capture as the rook is pinned
so you have to play something but here
we decided that it's actually best just
resigned here as there is nothing to be
done here so what you could try is just
captures the rook tears and there are no
other moves you have to capture the rook
and after characters rules you won you
repeat Queen f3 check Ruby g1 and now
rook the 8th and there is no defense
against what we do and this is what Gary
saw and that's why he resigned here if
you try a knight c3 to keep an eye on d1
just Bishop captures you remove the
defender and our rogue d1 check ends the
game on the spot and also if you try
something like h3 to give the King some
breathing room it's still rogue d1 check
King h2 and now of course Bishop
captures and g3 freeing up this diagonal
the only movies rook captures and now
rook the h1 delivers mate so game 2 goes
maxime paragraph as well as game 1 he is
leading now with 2 to 0 and we're gonna
check up on what happens next in the
match in between these two and is gonna
be extremely hard for Geary to get back
into the match he needs to win two games
on demand which is well which is
extremely hard to do but we'll see you
never know yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Holger handsome and Daniel Wilson
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - in my previous
video sure I think all for watching and
I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday